so this is our last formal presentation
after this presentation we have a panel
discussion with today's speakers so we
were thinking how do we pick someone to
solve the Institute because as you've
seen our scope has been fairly broad
right oh I mean yes they've been focused
on the city but we've been hooking at
the ancient city from 2000 BC 3000 BC
actually go all the way back I think our
very first day we were right 10,000 BC
just finishing up with the contemporary
you have a story good places like this
so I do think we found a great speaker
including however and I want to
introduce him to you his name is Steven
Tucker a gentleman on my left he's
professor and chair of classics at Miami
University he has one as we try to find
that many instances here numerous
teaching Awards including in 2014 he won
the national Teaching Award by the
archaeological Institute of America
that's a pretty big distinction also
actually I recliner from yesterday have
one do similar work he's done
excavations in multiple countries Italy
Greece Egypt also England is that also
English okay so that is a typo it says
three we should before it's also like
some of other presenters even us to have
work with the teaching company and he
caught my attention because either teach
a course support the teaching company on
ancient cities and when I was looking at
that course the final course in that
series or the final lecture in that
series is a comparison of ancient and
modern cities might be a great way to
ruff there anything out there thinking
about or in what ways is our continuity
boys you're just continuity with the
past
what are lessons we can
we have learned and that sort of thing
so I'm going to hand it over to get
Prescott up let's speak for an hour Q&A
and then we're going to try to wrap it
all up together
don't forget lunch thank you very much
it was kind of a daunting assignment to
wrap up five days of presentations most
of which I had not seen so that was kind
of exciting I was getting um messages
throughout the last few days from Eric
Klein on things he was briefing me on
what he had talked about it and Kent
Harlow and so on so this was this is
good so I appreciate that I appreciate
the shout out for my great courses of
course on the ancient cities as far as I
know Sam and my mother are the only ones
who have actually made it through that
so that was good to know that we doubled
the viewership on that one
so so this is all good for me thank you
I think that this is a great time in
human history to talk about cities and
the reason is that here at the beginning
of the 21st century there's two key
facts about cities that I think you
should be aware of as we launch into
this the first one is that for the first
time in human history in the early 21st
century I still consider this the early
21st century more people in the world
live in cities than do not and this is
the first time we have crossed that 50
percent threshold of city dwellers as
opposed to rural dwellers and that I
think is particularly makes this an
interesting moment the second fact that
I think is particularly significant is
that also in the 21st century for the
first time ever since
10,000 BC living in a city does not
decrease one's life expectancy from
10,000 BC up till the 1990s moving into
a city
was signing up to take five to ten years
off your life and quite remarkably we
have reversed that trend as well and I
see nods from all the people who are
living in cities kind of so I so I think
this is a really interesting moment to
think about what cities mean what they
do for us what they don't do for us and
really what the origins of that are so
in this presentation I'm going to take a
look at the legacy of ancient cities or
cities from the ancient world
I shouldn't say ancient cities anymore I
guess then we should say African cities
and and to see what sort of connection
so we can draw between the ancient world
and the modern one what what in fact
worked and what failures we have still
lingering from the principles of urban
design and practice from the ancient
world and then just to take a look I
think at where I'm where the successes
and failures are when we examine those
analytically and also I think and I'm
gonna go ahead and put this up front now
what we see in modern terms is that the
most profound successes in cities today
and the cities I'm most familiar with in
the West come when they adhere most
closely to the principles of city
building from antiquity boom there we
are and you can you can argue about that
with me later all right but first off I
wanted to say something about on ancient
cities huge topic of which you have
already heard from I think can Harl and
Eric Cline and Bullitt and others about
but I wanted to just say what ancient
authorities said about living in cities
because they talked about it many of
them actually the most the most notably
they of the Roman orator Cicero but I'm
not going to quote this reel because I
don't like him so when you do this you
can close this rope
according to many ancient sources living
in cities makes us human makes us better
and allows us to express who we are
politically and those three sources are
first off the Epic of Gilgamesh what is
arguably the earliest work of human
literature in the Epic of Gilgamesh
they tell us very specifically that you
can't be a real human unless you live in
the city living out on your own and the
wilderness doesn't make you human the
second one is Aristotle there on the
upper right who tells us that you have
to live in a city to be a good citizen
in the third and that is the notion of
being an engaged person in active in
your community is hippodamus of miletus
of whom i found two portraits neither
one of which I think would be actually
recognizable as hippodamus of my elitist
to say his mother but nonetheless they
fill in there in sort of a post office
wanted poster way and that is hippodamus
made the point that in fact cities
reflect who we are about which more in a
moment before we launch into where we
are today with cities I wanted to talk
about where we were most recently about
60 years ago and that is largely thanks
to the work of Robert Moses Robert Moses
who you guys have probably all heard
Robert Moses who was a Yale man came
here to Yale in 1905 if you walk down I
think it's York Street there's a big old
banner with Robert Moses his portrait
and for and with what statements about
his wonderful work particularly in New
York Robert Moses was influential in
American urban design and for landscape
really through New York and from that
example spread throughout what we might
call the modernist
School of Design this is a one of my
favorite photographs of Cincinnati Ohio
and I'm just the kind of person that has
favorite photographs of Cincinnati Ohio
which says something about me probably
nothing good but what it does is it
points out a lot of Moses's work which
you can find everywhere we were talking
about visit breakfast Sarah pointed out
the same issues in New Haven where
cities in the 1950s and early 60s
created enormous highways and the goal
was to move people in and out of the
city center with the I think laudable
idea that you're freeing people up from
the slums of the corn and abling them to
move out into the suburbs and control
their own where they choose to live and
work and so on but the practical effect
is that it cuts off neighborhoods from
the city center here you can see the
highways and Cincinnati and they come
right through downtown cutting off this
swath of land which actually eventually
just kind of atrophied and died in an
urban sense it was fascinating to see
it's it's making a comeback now
skyscrapers and large highways those
were pretty much the two keys to to most
as this plans for New York spread
throughout places like New Haven
Cincinnati pretty much everywhere the
new the current thinking not new it's
the current thinking however in city
design is what is called the New
Urbanism we can argue about that the
definition of that but I think you could
probably
neatly if inaccurately summon up as
cities that where you can I think it was
um did you say live work play the live
work play model was a was the phrase
that you used where you in fact can live
work and play in a smaller area of a
community and there's a huge amount of
literature
on the New Urbanism including and I
dearly loved this one sidewalks in the
Kingdom New Urbanism and the Christian
faith which I must confess I've not been
able to get my hands on but if anybody
has a copy I would love to borrow it
because I have no idea what's going on
there but one of my favorites and the
one I gave you the excerpt out of and I
turned over to all was was from walkable
City Jeff specks book which is based on
the New Urbanism the idea that cities
should be based around the human rather
than the automobile and this I think is
in fact where we see urban planning in
the West right now and where I see are
been planning based on the ancient model
and so a couple of key lessons so far
that lesson one on what the ancients
said about the city they are necessary
they make us human
they make us good and they make us
engaged lesson two is that cities
reflect culture this is probably
self-evident but I think it's important
to point out because they
self-consciously reflect culture and I
love these two examples from my Letus on
the left they're from the 5th century BC
the city that is designed or was
designed by hippodamus the famous
hippopotamus of my latest famous as in I
think six of us know who he is and in
100 AD the Roman colony of Tim GAD
fortunately founded by the Emperor
Trajan in 100 AD so my students always
remember that date what's interesting
about both of these is that they are
orthogonal II planned you know streets
set out and parallel perpendicular lines
giving us a grid pattern and blocks
which I think for most of us seems
rather an obvious way to design a city
but is not in any way a standard way to
design a city when you have an organic
irregular landscape to impose
sort of artificial order on it is in no
way natural but here's the big thing
about these is that both of these
designers are that is hippodamus of
miletus and the the Romans who followed
him created this pattern not just to
create a series of blocks but to create
a form that reflected the ideal social
order in this case Meletis hippodamus
was a Democrat in the ancient sense of
democracy and so he created residential
areas in which every lot was identically
sized he was making a statement about
government and about the role of
individuals in the community all men are
created equal before anybody actually
thought to write that down
similarly at Tim dad Tim dad is a Roman
colony made up like my leaders of about
five thousand citizens printed out so
that every lot is identical so that
every one of those five thousand Roman
colonists had the same size house and
it's to make a statement about their
equality under the government and their
status as citizens of Rome and so in
these cases I think they're tremendous
reflections of the ideology of design
and the government behind it there's a
lot more going on here as well of course
and I like Tim GAD because it reflects
some of the things that that I put in
that primary source reading the little
excerpt from Vitruvius and I'm not going
to ask anybody to raise their hand and
ask if anybody read that because that
never goes well in class and I always
end up you ever see The Avengers hairs
end up quoting Tony Stark in the
Avengers when he comes in and talks to
the guys and he says am I the only one
that did the
yes my spirit animal all right anyway
anyway what you see is in addition to
the in addition to the to the gridding
out and this imposition of of identical
community is is also a a statement about
where the privileged areas of the
community are in the center and at the
gates and you can't tell here because I
couldn't find a good plan with them with
topographical lines but this is the high
point of the community where the where
the temple of of Jupiter was the
capitolium the defining religious
identity and in that passage from the
Truvy's he talks about that
placing temples to create a as well as
we learned earlier a spiritual identity
in the community which is something that
is in fact ancient as well and we can
see examples of this idea of the ancient
manifestations of the of a government
and obviously the 4-momentum in Rome is
a classic example of government forms
and cultural values in stone it is in
fact it is it's the Constitution in
marble alright it is a statement about
how government works
what spaces you need for what organs of
government here in in well largely
marble it's it's a form of sort of an
architectural sclerosis okay a hardening
of the Constitution into into stone and
what you see is buildings that reflect
the values and needs of the community
know know how familiar you are with the
Roman Forum but I just wanted to point
out that there are in fact phases here
in the early part of the forum this area
in the center was all empty and we had
the Senate house
and then on the other end here the
Temple of Vesta which held the sacred
fire of the community literally its
hearth and in between was an empty area
designed so that the entire community
can gather and listen to political
speeches and so on
once the Emperor's took over that all
filled in with monuments all designed
really to celebrate the Emperor's you no
longer needed open political space
because they didn't want to open
political space we want a lot of people
gathering in public and so we have the
temple of the deified Julius Caesar the
temple of the deified Antoninus Pius the
temple of the deified Vespasian's and
Titus and so monuments directly to the
ideals of Imperial Government fill up
this space and so that the space
reflects the government of course I like
to give my students the the sort of an
anthropological analysis assignment of
the National Mall and ask them what they
see about our government of course I
teach the Roman civilization so we talk
about the meaning of the word the
capital but we look at the axis here
from the Capitol and the White House the
crossing there of course what things are
designed to to to break up this open
space where are the women in this
community when all of the monuments are
all to men although that's not actually
the case anymore there is a small
monument off to the side to two nurses
in the Vietnam War so
the quality yay
all right but it's very much a
celebration of men and we talk about
what the values of the community are and
what this represents so I think that
that lesson really is reflected in our
community as well so that's I said
lesson one but that was lesson two and
my number is already off all right okay
the next lesson where we put our
resources says who we truly are it's
true in the ancient world it is true
today it is in fact an existential
decision just say where we are going to
put our resources whether it is in the
Dunkin Donuts stadium assuming it got
tax breaks I assume it got tax breaks
what yes no of course good good I'd like
to think we're not the only ones stupid
enough to do that in Cincinnati I'm
somewhat relieved what about the do you
guys soon that the baseball stadium
it'll oh yeah okay all right sorry my
favorite example of where we put our
resources here is Jesus is the city of
paestum in southern Italy which was a
Greek colony of Posidonia and all the
Greek material there including three
large Greek temples 273 BC the Romans
come in occupy and found their own
colony and quite extraordinarily what
they do is they wipe out the entire
Greek public building complex in the
Agora what was the center of the Greek
city there and next to it they built a
Roman Forum
what's interesting and I'm sorry the
forum open area of the forum is here I
was pointing at these buildings along
the side because what's interesting is
that many of the buildings in the Greek
Agora were identical in form to the ones
that the Romans built in their forum but
it was important to them that they wipe
out all traces of the previous form of
government and re-establish their own
what they don't lie pout are the
religious markers and that I do think is
significant that they leave the massive
Greek temples and so they wipe out the
government forms they keep the religious
forms and so the religious identity of
the community actually is not altered
only the civic identity and so I think
it makes a statement about what the
Romans valued and where they what they
thought they needed to identify this as
a Roman community and by the way just so
you can tell when you're looking at this
this strip here of the excavated part of
the city is right up here this is the
entire walls and that's just where we
are here in the UM in the detail we see
smaller examples of this throughout the
ancient well I like this example from
Pompeii of public land reallocation and
this is a nice drawing of Pompeii from
the south Vesuvius of course is up there
on the north and we're looking here at
the theater the theater which predates
the Roman colony but the Romans kept it
including the quadra-port against the
four-sided portico because theaters are
not covered and after sitting there
listening to three Greek plays on stone
seats all day long you need to get up
and walk around and the portico allows
you to walk in the shade get something
to eat
stretch your legs in between plays
because you would go to four plays in a
day my students would die I can't go ten
minutes but anyway sorry that's my
problem
anyway there was a major earthquake that
hit Pompeii in 62 AD changed the change
the community in tremendous ways one of
the ways is it destroyed the previous
Gaudi toriel school of the community and
so what the Pompeii ins did was they
separated out that Quadra Porticus here
from the theater and turned this over to
the glow
toriel school a reallocation of a major
public space to another use which
establishes the identity of the
community that gladiatorial school was
key to the communities are really
identity and Garrett Fagan has written a
brilliant book on this the lure of the
arena which is a sociological study of
gladiatorial combat including a great
deal on pompeii so if you haven't picked
that up the lure of the arena you should
check that out
it's uh it's quite good in a modern
example of course back to Cincinnati I
told you that the riverfront had all but
atrophied thanks to Robert Moses has
inspired design there it's probably
violating the laws of guests friendship
to attack Moses in New Haven isn't it
all right okay all right no this is not
new ground all right good
all right what Cincinnati has done
recently actually is there tried to
re-establish connections to that land
between the Ohio River and the downtown
they've run a number of bridges across
as you can see and created a front for
the community so that when you come
across the bridges from Kentucky into
Cincinnati the first thing you see are
the largest buildings in the entire
community in terms of square footage and
they're all sports all right so we have
the football stadium the baseball
stadium and US Bank Arena where there's
a lot of indoor sports of Cour including
the roller derby team my personal
favorite and and pro wrestling is there
all the time too so that's a good one
but anyway what the city is decided to
do is to make its professional sports
venues the front of the community and
really it's identifying monuments it's a
reallocation of public land into a way
that really is designed to say what the
community values and how they identify
themselves and we can go into the
I love the names of these by the way
anybody know the name of Cincinnati's
baseball stadium I love this man Chris
by five all right yes a Great American
Ball Park which is a superb name isn't
it
because it just evokes baseball but it's
named for you want to go for a bonus
point here ah the great American
insurance company who paid for it you
pay for it you get your name on it
right that's an ancient pattern it's a
modern one so the great American
insurance company gets their name on
that the indoor stadium here I already
said was the u.s. Bank Arena okay so the
financial institutions get their names
on these community buildings and so it's
a really interesting sort of double
statement about what we value as a
community all right lesson three zoning
laws what zoning laws I'm sorry about
the colors on this there are a little
bright for these burning your retinas no
okay fine all right
this is a segment of the Roman city of
Ostia OST ia Ostia and I ripped it off
from the absolutely superb website of
Ostia Antica org awesome the Internet's
amazing isn't it it's not all porn I had
no idea okay anyway what I like about
this is that it makes the point that
this this multicolored extravaganza is
it makes the point that although in
antiquity or rather because in antiquity
they did not have zoning laws things
build up much more organically I would
use the term agglutinative Li what did
you use using use a glutinous if you use
aggregate thank you that was really good
too and that is the community builds up
and one way to take a look at that is
you can analyze the neighborhood
structure here in Ostia in a number of
ways but one of the ways I like is to
look at the bath complexes in town these
are largely neighborhood complexes where
people would go not just to bathe but to
exercise to network just to hang around
during the day to eat and drink and run
into friends to conduct business deals
and just there to exercise and get a
haircut see the doctor all manner of
activities and look in just this section
of Ostia one two three four five six
seven ten tomorrow salad thank you okay
eight okay yeah eight of these
essentially one per block and these
become sort of community centers and
what we can do is analyze the way the
city worked around these bath complexes
and it really makes it an interesting
case in in how the city develops because
I say there are no zoning laws what that
means is a lot of the community builds
up based on the tremendous powerful
motivator of self-interest particularly
commercial self-interest and looking at
another community just so you can see
that this is not that Ostia and the
baths are not the only way to look at
this you can plot the bars at Pompeii
and what you see is that the bars are
scattered throughout the excavated parts
of the city and presumably throughout
the unexcavated but they fall into key
locations mainly along the major avenues
as well as almost always on corners on
intersections and so people are creating
these little wine bars and putting them
on corners and very often on corners
right across from each other and and as
it turns out in fact and I was reading
an article recently on mattress stores
in the United States that if you build a
mattress store across the street from
another mattress store I had no idea
that these they both do better CVS oh
god that's a great example I'm gonna
steal that and next time I'm not gonna
mention you all right it's really good
Carla yeah car dealerships yeah that's
good yeah well those CVS and Walgreens
are like oh yeah yeah oh that's good
thank you yeah and the cars there right
yeah clustered oh man we see that
pattern in the ancient world no zoning
laws no overall authority that controls
these and so what you see is that the
community actually builds up where it
needs certain things now that lack of
zoning laws is not always a good thing
for example if you take a look again at
another part of Pompeii you see
workshops and every dot here is what is
known as a is called a workshop and that
is a place where things are made or in
ancient terms they would just call them
artisans hippodamus of miletus divided
his his city into three groups of men
the farmers the soldiers and the
artisans the people that made stuff and
these are places where things get made
but having these scattered throughout
the community as you do is not always a
good idea for one thing a lot of these
workshops involve
using heat to make bronze or to fire
pottery and things like that which leads
to parts of your city burning down on a
fairly regular basis another one perhaps
less obvious is a full
and this is actually it's a very nice
fellow naka sophal omeka of a man named
stefanos and there you can see the
reconstruction and there's the plan of
it and it's actually on this Main Street
right here in the center of town on the
major Avenue and a full annika is a
drycleaners shop which you might think
having a dry cleaner next door is pretty
innocuous except there's a couple of
features about ancient dry cleaners one
of the things is that one of the things
they use and some of you are nodding to
yourselves here what are they using for
dry cleaning fluid urine right fermented
urine which oddly enough does not smell
as good even as fresh yarn can you take
my word for this thank you they still do
that today by the way and I know this
because I'm in Cairo the leather workers
some use camel urine to to tan leather
and the smells in that then the leather
workers workshops are just unspeakable
and you get that here in addition to
bleach wool garments in antiquity you
know what they used figured if you had
the urine you sulfur you're burning
sulfur and the sulfur smoke bleaches the
wall and so you've got this marvelous
combination of sulfur fumes and and four
big open bats of fermented urine and
this is going to drop your property
values isn't it yeah exactly and so the
lack of zoning laws is not always a good
thing however there is a medium and I
would argue that the more
eclectic zoning for for lack of a better
term of the ancient world he's actually
more beneficial than a lot of modern
zoning and I selected as an example here
the village of Palatine bridge and I
selected it because it's a simple one
it's got only four zoning districts or
four Zoning categories and only one
major intersection and what they've
created here is that necessary
preconditions for this city to collapse
because they have created perfect
corridor development all of the
commercial districts are along these
true roads and I know that this is the
recipe for urban collapse because they
did this in my community and then they
rerouted the state and federal highways
around away from town and all of those
commercial districts died they weren't
integrated into the residential
districts and weren't where people lived
or played and and they all died and
moved out of town leaving in fact an
empty core and so this sort of zoning
unlike the lack of zoning in antiquity
actually leads to it works against an
integrated community and and it can lead
to well fairly rapid collapse
the fourth lesson has less to do with
commercial identity and more with
residential and that is residents leads
to urban engagement when people live in
a community they take they have a stake
in that community in my town where I
live actually one of the wealthiest guys
in town
he owns over 50 properties in the
community he lives in the neighborhood
just last year he just wrote a check to
the local school district to fund all of
the arts programming for the entire
district for the year because they were
going to cut the arts programming and so
he thought that was important for the
district to have wrote the check he
lives there he wanted there to be the
Arts in his community his residents led
to engagement and you see that in the
Roman world particularly as well and I
wanted to show you just this block from
Pompeii here's the entire block here and
this is one house which you can see here
just but you can see the the outline of
the walls of the house but you have this
enormous large house then you have
smaller houses apartments small shops
and all filling out the block what you
have here is a mixed-use block where
rich and poor people are living together
along with commercial establishments and
workshops and all in one space the
corollary to that that is that
engagement lead to investment in the
community is that social integration
reduces violence and we find that in the
ancient world and those communities in
antiquity where you have this mixed-use
where in fact the rich and the poor live
together work together and have this
common investment in the community
have much less urban violence
but it also means of course is that the
wealthy people like mr. Wilkes in my
community when they commit acts of
beneficence they do it in the community
so that they build bath complexes and
roads and aqueducts and so on
all right lesson 5 scale and walkability
matter and this is where I get most
directly into that sort of new urbanism
I don't mean sighs I mean scale the
scale of the community matters in terms
of not just how many people live in a
densely or not densely populated area
but what people see around them I've
been known in the past to say many nasty
things about Frank Lloyd Wright
brilliant designer his stuff sucks all
right
hail leek they're just terrible but
sorry but his notion of human scale
architecture makes sense as long as you
don't use Frank Lloyd Wright as the
scale seriously
you notice that the guy was 5 exactly
yeah dudes 5 8 right what if it's one of
his students Wes Peters was 6 foot 2
which is my height Wes kept running into
things and finally Frank Lloyd Wright
they had him in one of his houses at
West just sit out
okay but the human scale matters okay
and I don't mean sighs I mean scale you
can have human scale even in a large
city
case in point I think about Garrison
Keillor here and I do that probably more
frequently than was necessarily healthy
but in this case Garrison Keillor
actually makes a good point he moved
from Minneapolis to New York City and
his friends at Minneapolis all say oh
man could you live in New York so huge
you know travel all these distances he
said no you don't understand you know
that the grocery store the hardware
store are closer to where I live in my
apartment in New York than they were in
Minneapolis and Minneapolis you had to
get in your car and drive 10 miles to
the Home Depot in New York you walked
around the corner to the hardware store
all right um scale not size and scale
and walkability or in fact they matter
and case in point on their South Bend
Street obviously in Bloomington Indiana
development and I like to compare that
to Tim GAD 180 in Rome because what the
Romans did with Tim GAD is they ensured
that nobody had to walk more than 1,300
feet to get to any public facility and
that has actually become something of a
standard and you see that in the New
Urbanism 1,300 feet it's a maximum
anybody has to walk to get to a park or
any other public facility and that's in
terms of horizontal scale and
walkability there's also a verticality
aspect as well and you see this in the
ancient world I use Ostia here because
it's well-preserved enough that we know
that what we have is a community where
on the ground floor you have shops just
yes here at South under Street and then
above two-story apartments and here of
course they've just got these are
two-story ones but there's also
three-story ones two stories of
residential above and the ground floor
is commercial
and so this lesson I think derives
directly from the ancient world lesson
six cities are not for everybody and
these gentlemen have done a great job
talking about gated community is talking
about what these men talk about people
moving out talk about the issue of
suburbs right and we are facing with
that today thanks to the construction of
large highways and the ability of people
to move outside commuters we have of
course enormous suburbs and I think the
pretty much the natural extension of
that and that is the gated community of
which you can see the gates of one up
there here's an example of one of these
plant communities this is one of my
personal favorites here this is in Texas
rich woods and I got to think that that
was an intentional poem
these are all very rich very wealthy
homes here and what these communities
lead to is in fact a lack of community
there is in fact a very limited range of
property values in these areas you see
things you guys have seen these driving
down the highway I expect you'll see a
sign off to the side of the road that
say houses from the 850 is to you know
990s it's a narrow range which carries
with it a meaning um the people that
you're gonna be living next to are like
you okay they're all about what you're
like okay it's comfortable it's safe
it's reassuring and there's an urban
response to this or New Urbanism
response and that is the planned
communities that we have and that is
what we might term bypass implant
urbanism so right
great term I'm learning so much here
bypass bypass misses bypass stuff
outside but implant we have as well and
you see that for example in Glenwood
Park outside well as part of Atlanta
right
Glenwood Park yeah new herbalist
community there and what's particularly
interesting about this attempt to create
a new urbanist community in this implant
architecture is that they have created a
range of of prices of houses from in
fact public housing all the way up to
single-family homes and yeah it's
impossible to read so you'll have to
take my word for it
which I know is shifty but sorry and
what you have is townhouses apartment
shared as well as lots with
single-family homes and the I attempt
here was to blend these together so that
you have some of them next to each other
so you have that sense of community and
that sense of urban engagement so that
the single-family home owners here live
across the street from renters all right
and that everybody is in fact together
well professor Murray use the phrase the
death of the city as well and myself
lesson from the ancient world is that
cities do dot and sometimes they should
was tempted to use that with separate
some like Xena and the Ottoman Empire
we're here to stay
right cities are here to stay but not
always in the same form but not always
the same cities cities that are founded
for a single purpose that no longer
serve that purpose disappear and one of
my favorite examples is Daryl Medina
which is a well New Kingdom Bronze Age
city in Egypt it's a great little
community of workers in what can only be
described as ancient Egyptian shotgun
houses
these were workers who were assigned out
here in the western desert to build well
to build monuments to the pharaohs of
palace and and funerary monuments and
then when those were done they were done
and the community was just abandoned we
see the same thing in modern terms as
well I went last month to of to visit
butcher town Louisville because I take
it nice and a friend of mine lives there
for now
butcher town is a section of Louisville
that in fact is along this canal because
that's where all of the big well all the
butchers were in in Old Louisville so
that they could have a lot of water to
to wash away all of the byproducts of
butchering large amounts of animals and
so what you have is a whole community of
shotgun houses that that sprang up to to
house the workers when I say sometimes
they should die what's interesting about
elements of butcher town is that whole
streets are on in the floodplain of the
Ohio River and that is the city has
built flood walls with enormous gates
that go across the streets have you seen
these Rachel yeah okay parts of butcher
town are on the river side of those
flood walls and so the city has decided
that when the next great flood comes in
the Ohio River they're just going to
close those gates and everybody's houses
on that side are gone they've made a
deliberate decision that they're
abandoning that neighborhood of old
shotgun houses as I say a friend of mine
lives here so that's something of a
interest in that
and but the city has decided that the
community has served its purpose and so
I think this also is is a statement that
well is a is a concept that we carry
over from the ancient world and that is
communities can change they can adapt
but sometimes they don't and sometimes
other authorities decide there's time
for them to to go away
so there are my seven lessons there sean
connery cuz why not
so that's the end of what I had I'm six
minutes early this has never happened in
my entire life so don't I may have to
actually have you guys sign something
that says this didn't happen but I I was
hoping that maybe we could can have a
conversation if you guys had some
questions now that would be superb